Well, I also had a secret life while I was in the Air Force.
Yeah, I helped to build nuclear weapons.
What?
And this is what I had to wear.
Oh my gosh.
I was a football player.
That's crazy, honest...
Wow, it's crazy.
I played on the freshman team.
I played safety and wide receiver.
There's no way you played wide receiver.
Do you see my arms?
I went to college.
You went to college?
I dropped out to become a mom.
At the time, it was best for me.
It's putting my daughter first.
I said no crying, no messing up makeup.
Because of you, I know that I'm gonna end up surviving in this world.
I'm sorry.
You mean the universe to me.
Yeah, I'm just, I'm really glad you're my mom.
I love you too.